Westworld Season 2 Episode 8 starts with William,
near-death.
Akecheta turns up and speaks in Lakota, the
language spoken by Ghost Nation.
We know that William’s daughter Emily learned
this language , but William never did . Despite
his years of obsession with the secrets of
Westworld, he never learned to communicate
with one of the park’s most mysterious groups.
This shows how Ghost Nation, and maybe indigenous
peoples generally, are overlooked.
And it’s a reminder that Emily knows more
about Westworld than she’s letting on.
Akecheta saves William’s life, but not out
of kindness.
He says death is an escape from “this brutal
world” – and William doesn’t “deserve”
to die . Cause Akecheta remembers William’s
crimes, like killing Maeve and her daughter.
So he keeps William alive as punishment, to
“hurt” him . This idea of death as freedom
from life is similar to Dolores’ reasoning
for destroying the Cradle last episode . Emily
arrives to pick up her dad, and says she also
wants William to hurt . Maybe she just means
to hurt him emotionally – to force him to
face his mistakes, fix their relationship,
and come home like she asked him earlier . Or
maybe she’ll do something “worse” . We
know Emily’s involved somehow with the Delos
immortality project – maybe she’ll use
it to make William suffer.
In the Mesa, Lee looks over Maeve.
She had been so powerful lately, but now she’s
vulnerable and broken.
Lee had helped create Maeve – he wrote some
of her lines at least . And for most of the
season, he didn’t believe that hosts could
be more than their code . But after seeing
the realness of Maeve’s passion this season
– he’s realised she deserves to be free.
He apologises for getting her shot, and tries
to have her fixed.
But Charlotte finds out about Maeve’s power
to control hosts . Dolores warned last episode
that the humans would use Maeve against them
– so Charlotte might wanna turn Maeve into
her own tool for control.
So Maeve might need Lee’s help to escape.
But throughout this episode, Maeve uses her
power to see through the eyes of her host
daughter, and listen as Akecheta tells his
life story.
Akecheta, or Ake, once lived a peaceful life
with his partner Kohana.
This was thirty-five years ago, when Ford
and Arnold were first starting Westworld.
Arnold realised that hosts could become conscious,
and the park would be “hell” for them.
So he programmed Dolores to kill the hosts
and Arnold, hoping to stop the park from opening
– which again connects to that idea of death
being freedom from life.
This was the Escalante massacre, and Akecheta
saw its aftermath.
He found Arnold’s maze toy, which represents
a host’s journey to consciousness . So like
Dolores, Akecheta began his own awakening.
But before he got fully woke, he was reprogrammed
. Because Arnold’s massacre failed to stop
Westworld opening.
With investment from William and Delos, Ford
opened the park anyway.
And he made changes to the hosts.
Ake’s peaceful life with Kohana was replaced
with the life of a “brutal” warrior – a
“Dehumanized” bad guy for the Westworld
guests to kill . So for a while, Ake led Ghost
Nation warriors – in Season 1, we saw Ghost
Nation attacking Confederados, and attacking
Maeve at her homestead.
But Ake still knew that something was wrong
with his world.
He looked for answers, and found Logan in
the desert.
This connects to the end of Season 1, when
William tied Logan to a horse to discredit
him.
But Ake had met Logan years before – he
and Angela were used to convince Logan to
invest.
So maybe seeing Logan again reminds Ake of
this other past life.
And Logan tells Ake that Westworld is an “illusion”,
and there’s “a way out” – a “door”
. So Ake learns that this world is fake, he
has lived other lives, and there’s a way
out . So he searches further, and finds the
Valley.
This is the facility William built thirty
years ago, for his plan to record Westworld
guest data . It may be a place where copied
human minds are stored . In the latest timeline,
we’ve seen the Valley flooded.
Dolores says it’s a weapon . William calls
it his “greatest mistake” , and a “place
of judgment” . And Akecheta sees this place
as “A door” to a “true world” that
“contain[s] everything that we have lost”
, where hosts will be “free” “forever”
. This might not mean a door to literally
leave Westworld.
Maybe the Valley has a simulation like the
Cradle where hosts can live in a virtual paradise
– that could fit the talk of heaven and
death this season.
We’ll have to wait and see what the Valley
and the Door really mean.
But Ake believes he can “escape this world”
through the Door, and he wants to bring his
love Kohana with him.
But Kohana has been reset, and doesn’t remember
their relationship.
So he just kidnaps her til she remembers – because
true love, and a little Stockholm syndrome,
conquer all.
Ake and Kohana head for the Valley.
But on the way, Westworld techs find Kohana
off her loop, and capture her.
They don’t find Ake – maybe cause he’s
an older host who isn’t tracked properly.
Ake looks for Kohana back at her village,
but she’s been “Replaced” with a different
host, like how Clementine and Maeve were replaced.
So Ake searches all over Westworld for his
Kohana, til he realises she’s not among
the living.
Ghost Nation is vaguely aware of Westworld
techs taking and replacing hosts.
They call techs “shades” or “The ones
below” – some even pray to them . And
Ake calls Arnold “the Creator”, and Dolores
“the Deathbringer” . Just like people
throughout history, Ghost Nation is using
religion to give meaning to the unknown . Kohana
is in cold storage in the Mesa Hub, so to
reach her, Ake must journey to this land of
the dead.
It’s like the myth of Orpheus, who travels
to the underworld for his love Eurydice.
Journeys to the land of the dead are common
in myths all over the world .
So Akecheta gets himself killed and taken
to the Mesa.
Techs realise that Akecheta hasn’t been
updated in years – cause they only update
hosts when they die, and Akecheta’s stayed
alive all this time.
Instead of investigating this cock-up, a boss
tells them to just “Quietly” return Ake
to the park . This seems to be how Westworld
management rolls – they sweep problems under
the rug so no one has to take responsibility.
Which does help explain how Dolores and Maeve
got away with so much unscripted shenangians
last season.
Akecheta explores the Mesa – the world beneath
his fake life.
And he finds his love Kohana, among the inactive
hosts.
This is similar to the scene in Episode 2
with William and Dolores.
When William meets his former lover, he dehumanises
her, and calls her “a thing” to be used
. But when Akecheta meets Kohana, his love
is not only reaffirmed, it expands.
He says all the hosts in cold storage matter
to someone . Ake decides to save not only
himself and Kohana, but all hosts .
So Ake dedicates his life to sharing the symbol
of the Maze – it’s like a meme to spread
the idea of host consciousness.
Apparently all the mazes we’ve seen in host
scalps were put there by Ghost Nation, as
a way of spreading the symbol without humans
noticing . Which is hard to believe.
Techs would have to repair scalped hosts,
so surely they would see the symbol.
This might be some weird retcon.
But the point is that Akecheta uses the maze
symbol to help make hosts conscious.
Dolores’s awakening and William’s quest
last season follow the maze – which means
these arcs weren’t just planned out by Ford,
they were influenced by Akecheta’s work.
Sometime around Season 1, Akecheta meets Ford,
who’s checking out the maze symbol on host
scalps.
We have seen Ford confused by the maze, he
says the symbol “was meant to die” . Cause
to Ford, this was Arnold’s maze toy, Ford
never meant for the hosts to appropriate it.
Ford didn’t support host consciousness when
he opened the park, he only changed his mind
later.
So Akecheta’s whole journey to consciousness
and the maze stuff happened without human
help.
“All this time … a flower growing in the
darkness” . In Ford’s final speech before
his death, he says he realised that “someone
was paying attention”, someone who “could
change”, and he wrote his plan for host
consciousness “For them” . Maybe Akecheta
is that someone, a flower in the darkness,
who helped convince Ford that hosts deserve
to be free.
So Ford gives Ake a hint.
He tells him that soon, Dolores will kill
Ford – which was part of Ford’s plan – and
that’s when Akecheta should gather his hosts
and lead them to the Valley and the Door . Now
that Ford’s dead, Ake knows its time to
lead his hosts to salvation.
He might even bring humans – cause Ghost
Nation has captured human guests, and Stubbs
and Emily.
Akecheta’s journey has shown him there’s
goodness in all people – hosts and humans.
So that’s Akecheta’s story, from the beginning
of Westworld, to his present role as a messianic
leader.
And it’s all framed by his relationship
with Maeve.
We learn that during Ake’s travels, he was
once saved by Maeve’s daughter . So afterwards,
he watched over Maeve’s home, trying to
keep them safe.
Maeve thought that Akecheta wanted to hurt
them – but that was a tragic misunderstanding
. Of course, before Akecheta awoke, his men
totally did attack Maeve, which kinda undercuts
the message.
But the point is that Akecheta and Maeve now
share a bond.
Akecheta promises to protect Maeve’s daughter.
And Maeve replies “Take my heart when you
go” which is the same line Akecheta shared
with Kohana.
So like Maeve’s arc with Akane in Shogunworld,
this relationship shows a common struggle
shared by all hosts for their loved ones and
for freedom.
Unlike the Deathbringer Dolores, Akecheta
sees the good in all hosts – and maybe some
humans.
So he leads them to the Door, or the Valley,
and whatever lies Beyond.
So this episode is simpler than the last few.
No crazy battles or obnoxious time-twists.
And yet it tells a story that is both personal
and mythic.
It starts with the creation of Westworld and
an Edenic existence before a fall from paradise.
A hero walks a desert searching for meaning,
journeys to the underworld for love, meets
God, spreads enlightenment, then prepares
to lead his people to a promised land.
This is the cosmology of Westworld – a sci-fi
Bible weaved through the timeline by the love
story of Akecheta.
Westworld feels meaningful when it gets back
to basics, with a story about a person trying
to find their place in the universe.
There’s won’t be a Episode 9 video next
week.
Instead, we’ll do a livestream for Patrons,
and then after Ep 10 there’ll be a big finale
video to wrap up the season.
In the meantime, check out the Westworld subreddit,
the podcasts like Decoding Westworld, and
The Maze, the YouTuber HaxDogma, then come
back for the finale – and we’ll figure
out what this all means.
Thank you for watching this video, and this
series so far.
And thanks to the Patrons, including John
Morris, Adam Matthiesson, Stephanie Ramirez,
Raphaël Parrée, Livia Vasconcellos, Cody
Gordon, Daniel Crotty, Axel Friberg and SlowPepper.
Cheers.